thousands of years ago the sky gazers of
the classical world knew about six
planets Mercury Venus Earth Mars Jupiter
and Saturn thanks to the invention of
the telescope Uranus was discovered in
1781
but discrepancies in its orbit meant
that something was tugging at it sure
enough that something turned out to be
Neptune ever since scientists have
wondered if there might be yet another
planet in our solar system sometimes
called Planet X now astronomers have
strong evidence for one a planet roughly
the size of Neptune with a mass ten
times the Earth's and a thick atmosphere
of hydrogen and helium just as Neptune
was predicted based on its influence on
Uranus the evidence for Planet X is
indirect astronomers observe six small
solar system objects and notice they
come closest to the Sun in a unique
configuration there's only a 1 in 15,000
chance that this orbital clustering is a
coincidence it is much more likely that
Planet X has shepherded the six objects
into their orbits this explodes our
conception of the solar system because
planet X would loop around the Sun
unimaginably far away in a strange
elliptical orbit so far away that it
takes fifteen thousand years to make the
trip by comparison
Neptune's orbital period is 165 years of
course not everyone will be convinced of
Planet X until we have visual proof
researchers are now using one of the
world's largest telescopes Subaru in
Hawaii and they say they have a
reasonable chance of finding Planet X in
the next five years once spotted we can
welcome Planet X as the ninth planet in
our solar system
you